yes I think we'll still be age I don't
think that's going to be in the magic
pill that will suddenly stop aging what
I think will happen is that there will
be a slowing in the process of aging and
therefore a delay in the onset of
diseases and with better medical
research and better available treatments
and particularly with what's called
genomics so the introduction of gene
efforts and regenerative medicine which
means the ability to replace cells
tissues and organs we may see people
much stronger healthier and Vigors 120th
year I mean we will still have the
effects if we continue to expose
ourselves to the Sun we're going to have
wrinkles if we continue to smoke we're
certainly going to have wrinkles there
are things we can do to make ourselves
appear more attractive as we grow older
if we have the discipline to do it
alcohol to is a huge problem and people
don't realize how serious alcohol is
amiss in a minute
we only have one real example well that
was an interesting French well my name's
Sean comma and she had apparently a
great sense of humor right up to her the
end of her life which occurred at 122 so
she was quite remarkable I don't know
all the details but there's one great
story that at the end of one of her
birthday celebrations when she was like
120 and by that time of course
journalists from all over Europe would
come to see her and are all France and
at the end of one such occasion the cake
had been cut and everything was done
this young preacher journalist for the
hesitancy and his voice said well madam
comma I guess I'll see you next year
and she said in a nanosecond I don't see
why not
you look to be a pretty good health to
me
you